hello there I'm terren Edison and I play
out and join Rocket Man and today I am
going to be reading first tweets my
ideal weight is towering edited on top
of me my mum's gonna see this
Taron Egerton crack me open like a
walnut please I'm looking for age 28
gender male characteristics love singing
at Welsh dreamy eyes strong jewel killer
wink its town actin ominously prosper
very very lovely thank you so much I
didn't think it said killer wink I
thought it said something else then
saying that's actually quite quite quite
nice
thank you if I ever got to hook up with
a celebrity I dear God hope it's with
taran edge seems fine pip pip cheerio
ass quite proud of my essentially it's
big that there's no denying that but I
sort of don't really mind that just as a
little aside Tara legends voice makes my
heart brain lungs arms and legs go woosh
woosh it did allow fing cool thank you
very much I'm presuming that's good so
it sounds a bit like you might be having
some sort of cardiac arrest but I mean
that's quite nice thank you
anyway I just say that I'll let Taron
Egerton slit my throat with his jaw line
at any day Wow I mean that doesn't sound
particularly pleasant or sexy in any way
but I guess it's a 8 as a compliment so
thank you very very much
I got it from my dad I want
Taron Egerton to redacted in brackets
context is - ok I want our alleged sin
to something me well I have is something
in my something something and he can
something something oh my god this is
real that's really quite for a lot ok
gonna make me blush
whoever you are hi girls and gays it's
less than five months until we see a sex
scene between Richard Madden and Taron
Egerton
are you all ready because I'm pretty
sure I'm gonna need my inhaler or even a
defibrillator yeah
bye ticket just saying this couple of
months in advance
Taron Egerton owns my ass that's lovely
I don't I don't need any more I've got
plenty got plenty for one for one
nothing Taron Egerton Richard Madden the
both single mouth and send them my ping
way I have hands and I have holes and
I'm willing to put them to good use and
that based on the pictures is rami malek
thanks Robert Towne edge since thighs
town edges inspires Turner distance
thighs turn edge the thighs town edges
and thighs sort of ad infinitum I'm
guessing that probably in response to
the picture I posted of me dressed as
out in hot pants I can't argue with it
really clear
Taron Egerton is a white boy that I
trust to destroy my bossy what does that
mean really and then there's a fire the
one terror Edison can honestly suffocate
me with his thighs and my ghost will say
thank you thanks I'm glad that's
somewhere along the way little old me
has given you a kick thank you very much
[Music]